ben ali à une panne qui a été rafistolés
on voit une sangle on sait même pas trop
comment ça tient peut-être que son
esprit qui aide un peu et c'est toute la
structure qui est à revoir les poutres
la charpente les murs sauf que pour
stéphane le prix des travaux est bien
trop élevé mais c'était sans compter les
cent quarante mille euros de la mission
berne
c'est magique un peu entre guillemets
c'est comme gagner au loto finalement la
mission berme est financé par un autre
co est en fait c'est un peu comme gagner
au loto voilà j'aurais gagné au loto
j'avais mis l'argent dans la
restauration de la grange un dossier
bien rédigé quelques mois d'attentes et
là surprise il ya quelques jours la
grange fait partie des dix huit édifices
sélectionnés à travers la france
les devis sont déjà réalisés et les
travaux sont titanesques
ici le mur s'affaisse et la fissure se
creuse en effet ce nom là complètement
ont des casses en dessous on recourt une
grosse semaine en deux temps ferraillé
pour que ça fasse une grosse masse et
après on remonte le mur en silex comme
cela fait deux chaînes et de pierre
voisine c'est un joyau local
sauf que l'eau s'infiltre la toiture se
cassent la grange souffrent de ces
années d'abandon
grâce à cette restauration et dans des
générations ils pourront encore expliqué
que voilà en ce sens il construisait des
granges pyramidale dans le pays fort
après les travaux stéphanie stockera le
fond et y abritera ses animaux elle
restera une grange dit il mais il y
prévoit aussi des expositions des
manifestations et pourquoi pas des
projections de films